se um filme que falava o seguinte
pessoas não escolhem sonhos sonhos
escolhem pessoas e no primeiro momento
esse não fez sentido pra mim frio sempre
escolhi os meus sonhos e eu parei
refletir isso costumo fazer sentido
e aí eu pensei temos que seguir em
frente e lhe uma outra fase que falava o
seguinte a gente cansou de ver nosso
sonho sendo prostituídos na zona de
conforto e eu parei pensei quantas vezes
eu fiquei parada na minha zona de
conforto e quer saber eu vou pra minha
zona de confronto
bom hoje o que eu quero compartilhar com
vocês é sobre viver com ousadia viver
com ousadia para mim foi algo que
realmente mudou a minha vida eu quero
compartilhar uma parte da minha
trajetória da minha caminhada a forma
como eu amo a forma como eu vivo como
enxerga o mundo hoje ela é diferente
porque eu mudei a narrativa e vocês vão
ver que pode ser uma boa idéia você
também mudaria narrativa de vocês
bom eu quando eu comecei pensar sobre o
que eu iria compartilhar essa noite eu
não sabia por onde começar e aí eu
decidi fazer a mesma pergunta para três
pessoas que eu confio e que me conhecem
muito bem eu perguntei para a minha
primeira amiga e amiga desde os três
anos de idade nós somos amigas até hoje
a minha melhor amiga da faculdade e do
meu marido e eu fiz a segunda e pegar a
seguinte pergunta alguma vez eu já
inspirei vocês se sim o quê
confesso que fiquei um pouco com medo da
resposta porque são pessoas que me
conhecem tão bem e podia haver uma
resposta nua e crua e eu confesso que
realmente foi uma surpresa essa resposta
eis que a minha primeira
amiga me respondeu o seguinte sem amiga
você me inspira muito
o que me inspira a sua cara de pau como
esse na família explica elif ela falou
você não tem medo não você dá a cara a
tapa
você vá em frente você não tem medo e
ela me falou que isso mudou a forma de
enxergar o mundo
ela foi amiga isso foi foi uma chave que
virou na minha cabeça e foi bom então
vamos passar um pouquinho pra frente pra
ficar mais bonitinho definir a minha
amiga que se inspira comigo coragem
a outra amiga ela me falou muitas coisas
lindas e encorajou foi muito bom ouvir
tudo aquilo
às vezes na correria da vida da gente
não pára né pra falar algumas coisas mas
ela falou que o ponto mais importante
pra ela foi fé e por fim o meu marido me
falou que o que inspira ele é a ousadia
e aí ele me definiu em duas fases
ele definiu a ousadia de fora pra dentro
ea ousadia de dentro para fora e de fato
por muitos anos a e ousadia de fora pra
dentro me inspirou
desde muito nova eu gostava do que era
diferente eu gostava de sair do óbvio eu
gostava de quebrar padrões que me
conheceu sabe que eu usei por muitos
anos cabelo roxo e customizado nos
uniformes da escola fazia roupa com um
pano de prato enfim eu queria ser
diferente eu queria quebrar os padrões e
outro ponto também que marcou minha
infância foi a questão do empreender com
dez anos eu já comecei a fazer roupas de
boneca e os vendia por minhas amigas
porque eu queria ter o meu próprio
dinheiro
então sempre quis alcançar a
independência financeira e com 17 anos
decidi abrir meu próprio negócio uma
fábrica de roupas mas dessa vez não era
outra boneca era a roupa para ser um ano
e nessa mesma época da faculdade é nessa
mesma época da fábrica o curso de
jornalismo mas algo muito importante
marcou na minha adolescência
que isso me fez mudar a narrativa
eu sempre estudei em colégio de freira
quem aqui já subiu em colégio de freiras
sabe que é muito tradicional é tudo
muito quadradinho mas eu conheci meu
jeito de querer quebrar padrões
eu queria muito inovar a forma da
comunicação dentro da minha escola e aí
eu criei um jornalzinho fui apresentei
para uma diretora ela joão máximo mas
ela falou assim érika o colégio não tem
verba para bancar esse projeto
ela falou se você bancá aprovado
eu tinha 13 14 anos na época comentei
capital de giro para bancar um
jornalzinho mas não tava com
inconformado com a idéia de não fazer
nem quer saber
então vou montar uma estratégia fui lá e
comecei a vender anúncios e nessa
caminhada
eu bati numa faculdade para vender
anúncios e quando cheguei nessa
faculdade e me encaminharam para uma
mulher
e essa mulher e recebeu por lembro até
hoje dessa cena ela sentada com um
sorriso no rosto
apresentei a proposta comercial para ela
e ela não um portão que era um
adolescente de cabelo rojo falou assim
eu fecho o negócio com você mas se você
se tornar minha aluna de comunicação
social
na verdade eu nem sabia da existência
desse curso
meu sonho é ser bioquímica nessa fase eu
já estava entrando para o 2º grau eu fiz
o curso técnico em farmácia
mas para não perder negócio falei
prometo
enfim nessa vida e mal sabia eu que essa
mulher que estava sentada era jaqueline
a diretora da faculdade e eu me tornei
aluna de comunicação social dela em 2006
eu me formei em jornalismo mais uma vez
eu mudei a minha narrativa e mais uma
vez eu disse sim para o sonho que me
escolheu
muitas vezes a gente não escolhe os
nossos sonhos sonhos escolinha gente
enfim é em 2008 veio o convite da
silvana eu apresentar um quadro de moda
dentro de um programa de variedades e
também foi uma surpresa na minha vida
digamos que
o vinho não esperava isso e mais uma vez
eu disse sempre sonho
bora lá vamos pra zona de confronto e o
programa por um ano ele é na verdade era
então durante um ano ele vai colocar um
quadro um ano depois o diretor me
convidou para assumir um novo cargo
apresentará um programa semanal de moda
finalmente eu ia ter um espaço inteiro
para falar do que eu amo sobre moda
por fim nasceu o problema namora
programa na moda primeiramente ele foi
local
depois ele se tornou regional ele foi
estadual ea gente tava numa crescente e
estava muito feliz pensando esse vai ser
meu auge
chegamos na record news internacional
europa e áfrica e eu falei poxa que
bacana a gente tá tendo tantas
oportunidades e fala gente porque meu
marido me ele também trabalhar trabalha
comigo de biólogo ele virou meu
cinegrafista por um pãozinho
o donativo e nós trabalhávamos muito a
gente teve muitas oportunidades
incríveis nós conhecemos diversas
culturas viajamos muito e nesta fase eu
trabalhava muito e quando falo muito é
de virar as madrugadas e o que acontece
eu comecei a perder o foco porque para
mim é tem alguns valores que hoje eu
entendo diferente e na época o que
acontece eu deixei algumas prioridades
de lado
então eu não tinha e não passava tempo
com pessoas que eu amava então virou
rotina
meu marido dormir sozinha porque eu
virava todas as madrugadas
virou rotina não ter tempo para as
minhas amigas
virou rotina eu trabalhar simplesmente
para ganhar dinheiro
virou rotina e viver uma vida sem
proposta e nesse momento eu pensei e me
fez uma pergunta
érica quem você está se tornando o
coração grita calado e foi um momento
que eu pensei será que tudo isso vale a
pena
então eu mais uma vez comecei a refletir
sobre a minha vida e você pode até ter
pensado nós não espere que fala assim
para todos esses sonhos é tudo caiu de
mão beijada é tudo tão fácil apareceu
surgirem as oportunidades mas o que
muitos não sabem é que para cada
sim teve uma consequência
eu tive que abrir mão de muita coisa o
que muitos não sabem por exemplo é que
para eu aprender
eu trabalhei um ano de graça na tv e que
muitos não sabem também que em 2008 teve
uma grande crise mundial e as fábricas
foram muito afetadas e e nessa nessa
falou e cada escolha ter uma
consequência a gente acaba não se dando
conta de algumas coisas e nessa fase em
que houve essa grande crise mundial com
a minha experiência eu deixei com que 80
por cento da produção da nossa fábrica
fosse de pele
nós tínhamos a nossa marca própria ea
gente também fazer a pele que o private
label bouet que a gente desenvolve
produção para outras empresas
e aí o que acontece oitenta por cento da
produção ficou na mão de um único
cliente e quando teve essa grande crise
mundial
eu recebi uma ligação desse cliente e
ele cancelou todos os pedidos
ele rompeu o contrato com a gente e da
noite pro dia nós perdemos
oitenta por cento da nossa produção da
noite pro dia nós perdemos 80% do nosso
faturamento
e aí a gente senta e chora
é uma opção mas nós continuamos a ter
escolha ficar na inércia ou seguir em
frente e nós decidimos mais uma vez
mudar a nossa narrativa e foi muito
difícil porque
a idéia de fechar a fábrica pra mim foi
muito dolorido e eu tinha a sensação que
eu tinha fracassado pra sempre é muito
difícil passar por algo que você não
esperava eu nem imaginava como tinha
chegado a tal ponto
mas enfim a vida continua
é importante a gente ser vulnerável a
aceitar novas oportunidades e ter um
novo olhar em 2015
o johnny meu marido ele achou na
internet um intercâmbio nos estados
unidos me propósito era o que você acha
da idéia a gente mora fora do brasil
estudar três meses nos estados unidos
levante mais uma vez eu disse sim aí que
eu fiz
sair à tv e nós fomos fazer esse
intercâmbio em minneapolis e receber
essa como esse é que você é rica depois
e vamos morar em três meses fora do
brasil e assim não a gente não tinha
dinheiro sobrando não temos paz
milionários para vamos bancar é muito
importante nesta fase você fazer um
planejamento
então nós sentamos decidimos qual seria
nossa prioridade
assim nós abrimos mão de alguns
confortos e fomos encarar esse novo esse
novo desafio
então 2015 fomos é pra minneapolis e aí
começa a minha fase da ousadia de dentro
pra fora a 2015 então foi essa fase
melhor pois 2016
nós fomos para a flórida a gente foi
morar lá também por seis meses
efe foi uma fase também muito diferente
na nossa vida nós vamos estudar numa
organização cristã que tem como objetivo
fazer você conhecer deus e torná lo
conhecido através do seu melhor e nós
escolhemos que eles trabalham dentro de
sete esferas de influência da sociedade
e nós colhemos sites então nós somos da
arte na flórida
foram quatro meses mais ou menos de
curso teórico na flórida e depois foram
dois meses de curso prático na índia e
no nepal e pode passar e essa fase foi a
fase que eu considero que foi um grande
despertar na minha vida foi quando o
conecta comigo eu tive esse despertar
espiritual e foi muito importante eu
sair dessa zona de conforto para poder
enxergar uma nova época como seu deus
construir essa érika para construir uma
nova era então foi quando eu comecei a
ter clareza do meu propósito de vida e e
aceitação e eu costumo sempre dizer para
as minhas amigas que eu acredito muito
que todo ser humano tem sim um propósito
ea partir daí eu comecei a enxergar esse
propósito a primeira cidade nós paramos
foi dar maculina índia fica no interior
ao sul da índia é uma cidade muito
peculiar
foi muito difícil pra mim vivesse com
traje
por mais que meu pai japonês mas toda
nossa básico terá uma base cultural
ocidental
então é muito difícil você viver no
posto até eu chegar lá eu não fazia
idéia de como tudo isso acontecia lá o
nosso objetivo era servir as pessoas e
foi para fazer serviços voluntários e
ajudar no que fosse preciso então é essa
foto é na casa dele trosman então nós
trabalhamos na casa dele e prosas é pode
passar por favor nós fizemos também
serviços e em vários outros locais a
gente foi nas favelas nós trabalhamos é
com arts crafts com as crianças na
verdade a gente não
não escolhi serviço ou que tivesse para
trabalhar a gente fazia até em
construção ou trabalhei
então realmente eu sair da minha zona de
conforto
vivi algo que eu nunca imaginava que ele
ia viver e foi muito difícil três
primeiros dias na índia eu chorei muito
e eu pensei érika você tá louca você
está assustada
você está pagando pra sofrer porque a
gente era voltar a gente tinha que pagar
tudo e realmente não tinha conforto de
nada quase limpa sanitário gente tinha
direito a gente não tinha cama e colchão
para dormir
a gente tomava banho na bica agente
lavando roupa de bica
enfim um mundo muito diferente da moda
não tinha nada de glamour mas aí foi um
ponto em que eu parei bem
e que foi a primeira vez que eu senti as
interior é quando a gente ativa um
mecanismo chamado que o filho falou o
imt narcisismo
quando a gente tira o foco da gente
quando a gente pára de olhar só para os
nossos problemas
você muda nativa mais uma vez você
entende que pode ser diferente
então esse mecanismo funcionou muito bem
lá e aí eu voltei no meu propósito
inicial que era lá para servir as
pessoas
era lá para fazer o que fosse necessário
então realmente aquilo me trouxe uma paz
que eu jamais tinha sentido antes e
depois
é disso até eu quero falar para vocês da
solicitação que quando eu senti essa paz
no meio de desse caos
foi quando eu sentir realmente o que era
viver com ousadia
eu estou lendo um livro da bíblia em
hebron eo início do livro fala muito
sobre isso traduz exatamente o que é
viver com ousadia é um trecho do
discurso o homem da arena do ex
presidente americano e ele fala assim
não é o crítico que importa nem aquele
que aponta onde foi que o homem entrou
pessoa ou como ao todas as façanhas
poderia ter feito melhor
o crédito pertence ao homem que está por
inteiro na arena da vida cujo rosto está
manchado de poeira suor e sangue que
luta bravamente que erra que decepciona
porque não há esforço sem irmãos e
decepções mas que na verdade se empenha
em seus feitos que conhecem entusiasmo
as grandes paixões que se entregam uma
casa digna que na melhor das hipóteses
conhece no final tenho o triunfo da
grande conquista e que na pior
se fracassar ou menos fracassa usando
grandemente isso pra mim fez todo
sentido do que é viver com ousadia
então a índia ela me trouxe ensinamentos
para a vida
eo nepal foi a resposta do meu inquietá
mento mal sabia eu que o nepal lhe
reservava mais uma grande surpresa e e
chegando lá eu conheci uma ong chamada
meninas dos olhos de deus
essa ong é linda é maravilhosa
eu fiquei encantada mas ao mesmo tempo
eu fiquei destruída o que acontece
essa ong ela trabalha resgatando
crianças do tráfico sexual
infelizmente essa é uma realidade do
mundo e também do brasil mas lá no nepal
é essa proporção é muito maior e eu
fiquei focada porque eles me contaram
que crianças com 4 anos são levadas para
o tráfico sexual crianças são amarradas
e obrigadas a tomar hormônio que o corpo
crescer para receber de 30 a 40 clientes
por dia
eu fiquei chocada
gente isso é desumano
aquilo para mim foi um choque eu
conhecia aquela ong no outro dia tem um
desafio a gente tinha trabalho marcado
nas montanhas do nepal
acho que eu nunca tive uma experiência
tão louca de subir nessa montanha foram
mais de sete horas de caminhada e eu
achei que ia morrer nesse dia teve um
momento do jogo que a gente segue no
caminho porque mim não é que o meu filho
eu acho que eu nunca caminho em um lugar
tão íngreme como lá mas a vida é feita
de coletivo e nós estávamos em 9 e eu só
consegui porque eu tinha eu tinha
pessoas do meu lado cada um me dando
força me arrastando de todas as formas e
eu cheguei ao topo
e lá eu entendi que tinha muito mais
força do que o imaginado e só que nessa
caminhada
depois que eu descobri tudo isso das
meninas dos olhos de deus
eu queria muito fazer algo mas eu pensei
eu sou jornalista
com especialização em moda agora conheço
essa realidade e que eu faço sou uma
idiota eu pensei isso eu sou uma idiota
eu não posso fazer nada por essas
crianças e eu fiz uma oração
naquele momento eu achei que eu nunca
fazer na minha vida falei deus eu quero
ignorância porque eu não sei lidar com
isso porque eu pensava eu não tenho que
fazer e como eu volto para o brasil
simplesmente sabendo que isso é isso
existe e eu segui a minha vida não dava
enfim três dias eu me calei na montanha
silenciei e eis que veio uma luz de
fazer algo novo para essas meninas eu
não tinha dinheiro pra dar
mas eu tinha conhecimento e sabedoria
que tinha adquirido nessa caminhada que
eu podia compartilhar e aí foi quando eu
tive essa idéia de emprestar todo o
talento que deus tinha me dado para
essas meninas
existe um setor lá nessa nessa ong de
costura tem setor de um setor que é uma
fazenda tem uma escola tem esse setor de
costura e aí foi quando eu liguei pra
esse pessoal e falei olha eu gostaria
muito de dual meudon meu talento que eu
tenho dentro da moda e isso pode ajudar
vocês e eles me receberam de braços
abertos e foi muito incrível porque eu
passei três dias com essas meninas
desenvolvi um workshop de moda falando
sobre tendência
falando sobre cartela de cores e nesse
momento nós fomentamos um business elas
compartilharam comigo é sobre a idéia
que ela estiveram lá no nepal naquele
momento estava super na moda as belezas
casarem com o vestido de noiva ocidental
o nosso vestido branco e elas falaram
érika destaque com a idéia de montar uma
loja que não sabe se isso é legal porque
aqui no nepal só tem uma loja de
vestidos de noivas em seis vestidos que
você acha da ideia
próximo da idéia para quem adora a idéia
foi dentista
a funcionar vamos sim fazer um negócio
voltei para o brasil compartilha com um
cliente meu do do setor sobre a história
ea dureza para a sua causa e doou mais
de 400 itens para montar uma loja e essa
loja completou um ano no mês passado
levaram mais de seis meses precise tido
chegarem lá no nepal mas eu não desisti
porque eu sabia que ia dar certo e hoje
essas meninas ela se especializaram elas
não ficaram só com os vestidos elas
também apresentam hoje vários serviços
para a noiva se especializaram elas
fazem cabelo maquiagem é pulo oferece o
serviço completo e realmente eu fiquei
muito feliz porque eu aprendi que a moda
ela pode ser ferramenta de transformação
da humanidade
a gente precisa simplesmente
ressignificar porque eu tinha o
questionamento o que me inquietava sobre
o tal julgamento que a moda fútil
tudo depende é o de ser fútil mas se a
gente mudar narrativa não ela pode ser
diferente a gente e também eu entendi
que muitas vezes a gente pode ser pontes
porque quando tive que ela 15 que eu me
senti j é erro num primeiro momento
achei que não tinha muito que fazer
e olha só como as coisas foram
conectando como pontes foram
interligados e as coisas foram
acontecendo
então isso pra mim foi muito muito
importante e tudo isso foi possível
porque em algum momento eu decidi
assumir risco eu sair da minha zona de
conforto eu abri mão da minha carreira
profissional que pra mim ela estava
crescendo mas eu tava perdendo o foco e
eu tive que ser maior que o medo é claro
que eu tive medo
muitas vezes eu quis desistir não foi
fácil foi é dolorido
você assume é o seu propósito de vida
então o que eu tenho pra dizer é pra
vocês eu na verdade eu teria muito mais
coisas pra dizer
mas o tempo é curto eu tive também que
processar nessa volta ao brasil porque
lidar com a volta com essa cultura
diferente também foi bem difícil então
eu a grande lição que eu tiro disso tudo
é que muitas vezes não se trata do que
eu quero
se trata do que eu posso fazer pelo
próximo e eu aprendi muito mais
valorizar o ser do que o termo porque
hoje nós que eu aprendi que os valores
das pessoas são todos iguais e eu tenho
pra dizer pra você que você tem sim uma
missão e eu quero te encorajá a você
fazer algo que você nunca fez estão
preparados
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]